hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm sat here with hakeem hakeem is the
elected officer in london of the labour
party
uh you saw my video i did the video was
about rent control
and hakeem messaged in the chat and said
can i come and have a debate with you
about rent control so here we are
in my home office uh so hakeem what made
you want to come and talk about rent
control with me
thank firstly thank you for the
opportunity of coming samuel i really
appreciate it
i want to thank you for the opportunity
that you've given myself
and other academy members being able to
learn about property education the
normal thing
these things that aren't taught in
schools but that should be
um and look uh
before i got into property or before i
got into business i was first
interested in politics and the reason i
wasn't i'm interested in politics is
because
you know i grew up in inner city london
on a council estate
and i saw you know the challenges
that come with um the challenges that
come
in those estates and i
was i went to
an inner city london school for
until i was about 13 14 years old and
luckily or not luckily i'm i'm
grateful that i was able to have that
opportunity um
and learn what it's like to
live in london um
in you know in that area in those sorts
of areas
and then um when i was 13 or 13 14 years
old my mum moved me
to a countryside area in huntington in
cambridgeshire
and it was in that area in that in the
school that i went to there
um it was seeing the differences in
terms of the life
chances and the life chances and
opportunities
between the between an inner city london
school
from a sort of low low income area
to a more middle class or so to speak
and a more affluent area that's what got
me interested in politics in the first
place
that's why i studied at a level and then
at university
and it was really understand i really
wanted to understand
well firstly why there were why the uk i
feel that the uk is such
um an unequal society
yeah um i really wanted to understand
the reasons why and what i could do
about it
um so that's what that's the reason why
i then studied
european history government of politics
um
english literature et cetera and then
went on to university to do politics
and then i ended up choosing the labour
party as the party that i feel
that reflected my values around
not having i don't believe in monopolies
i believe in having a diversified market
i believe in offering opportunity to
small medium enterprise um
i like tesco's like everybody else but
you know i i prefer to see
more corner shops and butchers
and bakers that are owned small
businesses small businesses yeah great
families just small families just like
yours and mine and russia's
as opposed to having big large
corporates sort of
owning everything you understand and
really concentrating
all of the wealth in the hands of the
sort of small few yeah so
the reason why i baxter deacon's a
candidate is because sadiq
for me shares those values the reason
why i chose to
become a member of the party and the
reason why i'm active in the party is
because
our party shares those values and um
i also agree in this case
um also ontario's policy on rent
controls
and that's the reason why i came here
today and that's just a bit of
background about me
yeah that's great well firstly i just
want to say you know
respect for coming on the show and i
love debates
i love being challenged i'm open-minded
i think rent control is a bad idea
however i'd love to hear why you think
it's a good idea and we can thrash it
out
sure so firstly i think a few key facts
so did you know that for example
you know the average private rented home
or one bed
in london is uh more than it costs more
than the three bed
nationally in in england um so
that to me is quite a it's quite a
shocking statistic
i know that a one bedroom flat in london
would
to rent would be somewhere you know
around
1 100 pounds sometimes as great as 1 400
pounds
yeah if it's a two bedroom flat um we're
talking about 1400 pounds right up into
about 1800 pounds and then
a three bed flat anywhere between one
thousand eight hundred pounds and two
thousand
five hundred pounds and that uh as a uh
that tends to price out most londoners
that come from you know out any school
anywhere
any sort of low income family or even
medium income earners can't afford
uh to rent in london we've already been
priced out of the owning market as well
and that's the reason why you have back
sedek's policy and that's the reason why
i believe in it
and it just goes to show as well that
actually up to one in four
londoners live in the private rented
sector so that's
25 of the population of london as 8.4
million people
and then on top of that um most of
us if not most of us if not all of us
apart from you know
a relatively small uh sort of percentage
of people
can actually afford to live and rent in
london and that's the reason why
i think it's the right policy okay so i
mean i understand that london's
expensive
you know i totally get i totally sort of
get that but
so do you think rent control would bring
down the rents because that's not what
it's done if you look at places like new
york and california
when you bring in rent control although
it caps it what happens is you end up
with a shortage of houses right
so i appreciate that view and to to a
lot
to some extent i do think you're right
but i don't think it's a simple policy
of rental control or non-rental control
i think it's actually about how the
policy is really implemented yeah
so in this case the mayor sadiq khan
he's not asking
for he's not asking the government
permission to implement rental conclude
rental controls what he's actually
asking for is for the may the office of
the mayor to have the powers
to um create a
private rent a private rental commission
now
what this really means is well
firstly starting from the sort of time
when we talk about politics
the my first politics tutor and lecturer
at a level he always used to say that
politics is the art of compromise
politics is the of the possible and a
good political decision
leaves uh no one happy but everything
everyone okay and what we really mean by
this and i really agree with that
statement and it really
uh sort of rings home with me and what
we really mean
by this is that
in something we call real politic
it's really about balancing interests
employers
versus employees uh consumers
versus producers and
landlords and tenants yeah problem is
that
depending on your perspective we all
believe that we worked hard
for our money or we worked hard uh
to build our businesses or to to or
within that job for that employer
but um when it then comes to
deciding how you want to organize
society
and who should pay this tax or that tax
on more tax or less tax
everyone from their own perspective
always believes that they
that they should pay less or that
they're entitled to more yeah so from
that perspective then
as i believe that it's politicians
um especially from a labor perspective
it's it's their responsibility
um and i'm an officer not politicians
but as
as um the ethnic minority forum
secretary within the london labor party
it's my responsibility to make sure that
um all the interests are balanced yeah
so it shouldn't be that
that uh landlords overpower tenants or
tenants overpower landlords
it should be banners there needs to be
to make sure
that um everyone gets equal opportunity
and
the opportunity to to own the
opportunity to be able to pay
decent and i have decent and proper
housing and i know that these are values
that you and i share
yeah um and that you know in most cases
um landlords uh
or in in our case where we have proper
property education
and we have the right values yeah when
it comes to bringing
bringing decent housing with good fire
safety regulations and things
um you know we we implement those values
but unfortunately
not everybody does and as a result um
you know bad landlords can give good
landlords a bad name
and also some tenants are just
some some of i'm and just for context
i'm a tenant right now as well and
myself
right and thank god the rent control
isn't a thing in my area
because because if it because i want to
pay a really high rent
in fact i have i have a problem that i
can't find enough
nice houses expensive houses to rent
because there's not many out there
so so i mean if rent control came either
as a tenant from my perspective how i
see it i respect your opinion
but from a tenant's perspective from a
developer's perspective
from a event investors perspective from
every which way
you look at it the effects of rent
control over time
are bad for everybody the only people
that rent control the only person that
wins with rent control are the
politicians because they look like
they're
they're trying to do a great thing like
sadiq for instance saying he wants to um
bring in rent control everybody i think
he's saying that because he wants to get
votes i think he's saying that because
people are like yeah but actually
it's devastating everywhere it's touched
i can't see that it's
it doesn't make any logical sense so i'm
very open to being
you know proved wrong but i mean can you
name one
one place one city where rent control
has actually brought out
positive effects because i i can't i've
looked at all the different
uh effects and statistics of what's
happened it's always been bad
would it be okay if i answered that
first starting with what you first said
about depending on the
the perspective so you mentioned a good
you make a good point there and
and um i appreciate where you're coming
from
um but you said a tenant
a developer or an investor yeah now
in terms of when we're talking about
eight 8.4 million people that live in
london
most a lot of people are tenants yeah
not everybody's a developer
and definitely not everybody's an
investor so in terms of
siddiq's job and our job
as the labour party to represent to
represent all the interest
and balance out policy making to make
sure that as many people as possible
are served in the best way in that sense
then
it in that sense then it's in in that
sense then
um developers
and investors who well firstly
there are different typologies of
developers and investors
so good developers and good investors
like yourself will have
great values and we'll implement them
and we want
we want more people like you
to be in the private rented market
however
other types of developers and investors
who maybe don't care
who don't who don't care about fire
safety standards
who don't care about tenant living
conditions
who don't care about about deliberately
manipulating the market to make to
price out most average londoners or most
londoners from being able to rent a
bedroom house
it's for those reasons why um why
siddiques and ycd believes
in implementing the policy and
in that respect then i i hear what you
say
or as volatile would say you know i
disagree with what you say
but uh but i'll defend to the i'll
defend to the death you're right to say
it
with that being said um i don't feel
like
that i feel like
sadiq's policy uh represents
more people and serves more people yeah
in that regard and let me just be clear
about another thing as well
um the mayor isn't asking he's not
asking
for powers to implement rent controls
that's the short version
the actual when you actually look at the
actual detail of the policy and see how
it
is going to be implemented what we
actually want is to create
a private rented commission and and
the the way that private rented
commission will actually be structured
and the way it will operate is
you'll have um a you'll have
and bear in mind um you'll get more
detail on sadiq's website
but obviously i've seen the on well in
the actual commission itself yeah
you'll have private renters that have
some representation on that board
as well as developers and investors as
well so in that respect then
we'll be making policy using the art of
compromise
using the after possible and making sure
that everyone is represented in that
decision yeah you know that everyone is
okay
even if everybody isn't it so as i said
politics is really the of compromising
of the possible and it's about making
sure that everyone's okay
and in that respect we need to have a
more balanced policy
we need to have balance of interest and
we need to make sure that people who are
who are in private who are private
renters tenants
have more of a sway and a
a bigger slice of the cake and more
representation and a bigger voice
when it comes to the pricing of london
properties because
to be honest the fact is uh people like
you and me
and people like you know some of the
viewers watching at home
um not all of us can afford
you know 1 100 pounds for one bed or 1
400 to 1800 pounds for a two bed
or up to 2500 for a three bed that's
just it's not a realistic expectation
and it's not fair
as well that in some cases um you could
i want
to even rent a a single room in a
in a six-bed hmo property in london it's
gonna cost you 950 pounds
per calendar month like that is just
ridiculous pricing and most people can't
afford that
and then in some cases the housing the
standard and the stock of the housing
isn't even good
yeah so sadiq is absolutely right to
actually want to tackle this issue
and it's not about where have the where
has the rental
uh has this worked in other cities well
well
um actually just can you clarify what
you mean by that
what's clarified the question on that so
rent control
i mean every every it used to exist in
the uk
it was a thing and then it got it got
abolished because it sucked and because
it didn't work
it's a thing in new york it's a thing in
california
the two states with the highest rents
and the most homeless people is where
rent control is
they brought it in scotland in 2017
18 and and i've said that it's been a
flop the scottish council
the scottish government was a flop they
brought it in berlin last year
and as a result berlin are
have a massive housing shortage so i
just think i get the idea i understand
that it's like it's a shame that
people are priced out of where they
might have grown up because the rents
have gone so high
but i think that i believe in a free
market i think that a
any any business you have a willing
seller and a willing buyer
i i think that rent caps my properties
the rents are already capped and all of
my properties and they're capped
because people are only prepared to pay
what it's worth and it's about supply
and demand so i think saying
if you say in london actually we're
gonna we're to say
you know the rents are capped this this
this amount or this amount
or they have to go up in level of
inflation or whatever however
however it's done what's going to happen
is it's going to put off
developers and investors go into that
area and at the moment there's a massive
shortage of houses in london
so what they should be doing in my
opinion is trying to encourage
developers
coming into london not deter them by
bringing in rent control
and whenever rent control is brought in
it deters developers
it deters investors and it's not about
trying to look after the tenant
i'm not saying because i'm an investor
and developer i'm going to think of it
from the
investors i don't care about tenants i'm
actually thinking from the tenant's
perspective
if you're a tenant the way to make
housing more affordable is to create
more houses
but rent control historically every time
it's ever happened in the in the world
historically every time rent controls
come into place
it's actually made a shortage of houses
much worse
therefore distorted the market and and
created more homeless people
etc so that's why i'm against it i
understand the concept i understand the
idea
and i think the prop the problem is
people and
educate me enlighten me help me out but
the way i see it is people just think
oh that's expensive that's not fair it
should be less but they're not actually
thinking about the long-term effects of
rent control
and i think sadiq probably knows the
long-term effects i think he's just
saying
oh yeah let's bring in rent control to
get votes respectfully
i i disagree with that and and look
you mentioned that you believe in the
free market yeah um
yes the free the free market is good but
a free group a free market that is also
regulated is really important
so let's take for example while we're on
the topic of housing um
before the estate agent market wasn't
regulated and we had
agents charging charging vendors on one
end
of ridiculous fees and also tenants on
the other end
so then a pilot for so then um the
policy was brought in to
prevent uh agents from being able to
charge or essentially make money on both
ends and charge tenants ridiculous fees
and that and that is an example of where
it's not quite
it's not a black and white answer yeah
it's shades of grey yeah
um and that's an example where we where
a policy was implemented that actually
um actually represented and helped and
helped more people at scale yeah because
now now
um we as tenants don't need to be paying
those fees anymore and agents don't need
to be ripping off both sides
obviously i understand we have there's
lots of good agents and and you work
with good agents and i work with good
agents
but agents but it's just about the point
is about regulating the market
is important yeah so let me be quite
answer some of the points she made there
about other cities
well firstly uh the labour party
learns uh and we in politics we learn
uh from the examples of other cities and
it is true that
rental uh rent caps are a
are in sort of in principle
new policy initiatives that are that are
being launched in very in different
cities
london is a world city and what do we
mean by world city is
um a city where you have um
great fields of human endeavor in
technology
in art in science in um
in uh culture and communications
wherever you have
um advancement uh in human endeavor in
these types of in
all of these different fields or
especially when you have all five fields
and one it's known as a wild city
so com so a fair comparison of london
london is what you what you'd call a
rank one world city
a fair comparison for london would be
somewhere like new york
yep but it wouldn't for example be
somewhere like i don't know like like
madrid
because that's a slightly lower tier in
terms of world city if you
if you judge world cities from that
perspective um which is what a lot of
political scientists do
yeah so um in that respect then
we learn if if rent caps as a principle
are new because we've never had um
we've never had um such housing crises
in london and in new york and in
singapore and in hong kong
we are learning from how those policies
were
were first introduced and secondly
implemented in those cities
so when you're making when you're making
policy from that perspective
it's not just about like firstly is the
philosophy of of implementing
rental control is a good one is it a
good thing
for us to want more people to have
access to housing and fair
fair priced housing you know a base
human needs well
yes it is i think you'd agree with that
yeah so
it's not necessarily about what the
policy is well we can all agree that
that the aim of the policy is a good one
yeah but what it is also about is how
it's actually
implemented so on that regard in that
regard then we've learned
from we've learned from how the good
things that they did in
new york yeah and the things that they
didn't do so well we're not going to do
that
also the the actual policy making
process is very
different so um do you know much about
how how we actually
make i mean to what i mean to what
extent um
have you you have you had an opportunity
to do
research on how the process that we go
through to make a policy like that
i mean i know a bit i failed about rent
control i wouldn't have done a video
if i didn't know you know about it yeah
so that's fair enough
so it's a clear sort of policy process
so firstly um firstly
um we would invite
tenant organized tenant representative
organizations and landlord
representative organizations
to come and be a part of that policy
making process
yeah then we then um
we would um draft that legislation with
equal representation from both sides
and we as as well not we because
i'm not i'm not uh sadik who is uh
the the mayor and also the councils
themselves
the politicians will sort of sit in the
middle between the two sides and seek
and seek to form um a a compromise
and a uh a sort of like i said
a good decision that balances out all
the interests
um then there'll be a consultation
they'll reach a policy position and
that'll go through committee
with deal with different parties from
different perspectives depending on the
council
and then there'll be a consultation with
the public where
members of the public so for example if
that was to happen in let's say
in let's say southwark council there'll
be a public product there'll be a public
consultation where
where it'll be well advertised and
anyone from the public can come and take
part in two or three meetings where
we'll actually
ask people what do they actually think
about the policy do they agree with it
and what they actually say and what
people think and
bear in mind that it's our duty to
actually represent
represent uh members of the public and
represent
those people which we were elected to
serve yeah and people who don't have a
voice
people who do people who are paying
ridiculous ridiculous rental fees
then um the views
of the actual public and the views of
of of residents and tenants will be
taken into consideration as well as
landlords and developers like yourself
yeah tenants like yourself i know you
you you straddle yourself i'm a tenant
an investor developer
i think did you say that it's a new
thing though rent control
but it's not a new thing is it it's been
going on for
decades yes so
if it would be okay you'll just uh just
finish that last point there yeah and
then i'll come back to you
so thank you um so
even then after that consultation is had
yeah
then we'll trial the policy
we'll try it i'll get the feedback yeah
and then and then amend
and retrial it again and in that organic
way
the policy will that policy policies
like rental control
and in this case it's not at the
beginning yet it's not even it's not
that the mayor is going to implement
that with a stamp
yeah what do you think what do you think
so so why do you think so yeah so
so to so do you think that's a good
process no go through
no i think why not well the process of
bringing in laws might be a good process
yes but i think
rent control is a bad philosophy that's
never worked so the mayor's not asked
the mayors and asked
for the mayor is not hasn't asked for
the party to bring in rent control the
mayor's asked for
the power the mayor the the office of
the maid
at the moment doesn't have the power to
bring forth uh a private rental
commission
that all that that represents all sides
that will discuss and and bring that
policy together but
those aren't the powers that the mains
asked for okay sadiq said that there's
overwhelming arguments for rent control
yes what are they overwhelming arguments
for rent control
okay so um the fact that
in london most people are priced out of
the rental market but how's
rent control gonna help that
how's rental rent control going to help
it
we believe that
1 100 pounds for a
for a one bedroom property is completely
up it's completely ridiculous
so it's one thousand four hundred one
thousand eight hundred so it's two
thousand five hundred pounds
for three bed now we're now
um in other cities like like new york
mike berlin and like those others
um it's true that they've been tested
and they haven't been perfect when
they've been implemented well they've
devastated
the market in your opinion however yeah
there are
there are there are there are
organizations who argue they've
devastated them
there are organizations that argue that
they're in support of them for example
the new economics
foundation and generation rent in the uk
is in favor of them and they've also
gone through a process of also analyzing
and looking at the data and actually
going and speaking to speaking to
tenants and landlords in
new york in berlin but when they're
scottish when the scottish
government themselves say it was a flop
and you just got to look at the
statistics like in berlin
the fact that they're 50 behind on their
housing
um on their housing shortages in berlin
they only brought it in a year ago i
mean the stats
in new york there was a direct
correlation
and economists have said that over two
hundred thousand rental units
became void and empty as a direct result
of
the um rent control i i don't think
anyone's
arguing i question our question to the
extent i question
the the extent to which one that you can
draw a direct causal link between rental
control
and and the fact sorry would it be okay
if i just finished this one point yeah
sure i question the extent to which you
can say that rental control has caused
50 of a housing shortage no there's a 50
housing shortage the reason there's a
housing shortage in london
is is because is because quite frankly
um the department for communities and
local government
and the and the the uh the central
government the conservative party that
are in power
uh from our perspective uh are in the
pockets
are in the pockets of big developers and
have deliberately
uh completely underfunded councils so
they don't have the ability to actually
build housing and build housing in the
way that we need
um so so
therefore i suppose the kind of the kind
of
core point that i'm making is yeah i
appreciate your perspective that you're
not in favor of rental controls but i
don't think it's a fair statement to say
that rental controls are the reason
why housing shortages are are remain
uh that's what the councils have said of
the places that are brought in no the
councils haven't said that
no some some councillors who
are who who may be conservative
councillors
who may be counsellors uh you know who
may have
taken maybe you know
shareholders or have stakes or reasons
why they would be in the fate
in favor of being in favor or in line
or aligned in terms of their their
positions with big developers have said
that
yeah and they are not representative of
everyday londoners they're not
representative
of 8.4 million people they're not
representative of you or me
they're not representative of of you
know i go i go canvassing and i actually
i'm not people i knock doors and i'm on
stores
and for most average londoners um we
need
we and i'm saying that as myself i'm a
tenant i'm 27.
i'm a tenant um i live i live in a hmo
i've been priced out i've been priced
out of the
private rented uh market um
apart uh just like like everyday people
like like like normal people
who can't afford to pay 1100 for a one
bed or 1400
between 1400 and 1800 for a two bed or
eighteen hundred to
twenty five hundred for a three bed um
it is we believe and i believe
um so i've just i'll speak until it says
to me i believe the duty
of politicians of elected officials who
have been elected to serve their
communities
serve our communities to make sure that
the interests of tenants of
good landlords and
even even the landlords who we would
like to see
do better things you maybe have the
right the they have
the right goals but maybe they they're
just they don't they don't quite know
they either have over-systemized their
businesses or they don't know how to
they don't know how to do things
properly yeah it's our it's our duty to
make sure
that the interests are balanced and to
be honest
weighted in the favor of the many not
the few and that's why sadiq has brought
the product that's why
sadiq supports the policy that's why the
the office of the mayor
should have the powers and sadiq himself
who's a great candidate by the way
i don't know how much you know about
siddique but sadiq grew up in london
uh it's from tutin his dad was a bus
driver
uh sadiq has done some fantastic work um
he was a lawyer he was a lawyer before
he was the mp of tooting
and then before he was empowered tooting
then he was mayor
um in his in his uh
when he when he was a performing lawyer
he represented a lot of ethnic minority
uh communities and ethnic minority uh um
uh defendants and and people and ethnic
minority people who wanted to prosecute
people who just employers sometimes even
government organizations and and
institutions
who who were um
you know in the best case
um ignorant and in the worst case
racist sadiq khan is a great candidate
he's made of good stuff
i believe in i believe in him i believe
in the party i believe in labor values
and just on this particular issue when
it comes to about housing
uh we believe in serving the interests
of as many people as possible
yeah and and offering the opportunity
for every everyday people to be able to
actually afford to rent rent in london
and yeah like i said one in four people
one in four people in london in the
private head here rented sector
um and um yeah i'll just
get that fat from there the average the
average price the average rent
for one bed in home in london is
uh is more than a three bed nationally
and that can't be right and that prices
everyone out and that's why
and that's why yeah that's why i agree
with it and
like i said it's not that the mayor
wants to put
um wants to just enforce
rental controls like that on people no
it's just that we want to have a proper
process
where everyone is represented in those
decisions
and in the end uh everyone's okay i
understand
and i'm not here to say siddiq's a bad
guy i'm not here to say that labour
party you're a terrible party
i'm talking about rent control yes so
where has rent control it's been it's
happened many many times in many parts
of the world
where and when has it ever brought about
a positive change
and actually achieved the objective
which is
it's brought down the rents it's helped
the the many where has it ever worked
it worked to a large extent or it is
working
yeah because firstly it's not a it's not
a it's not a
bang and it's done it's a process so
what works so so
if i if i may it's a process so
the process is working in new york the
it's good it's good it's being yes it's
true that
um you know when we first bring a new
policy in you don't you don't always get
it completely right
the first time you need to implement you
need to develop you need to learn from
your example to learn
well that's why in london and bear in
mind can i just point out that
regardless of
what what people think about traveling
in this city or that city
london is a very unique city london
london
like i said is a world city it's a rank
one world city
the only cities that can ever get that
that that
that are perhaps comparable with london
are cities like new york
shanghai hong kong and
in this case london's personality is
also very unique
in the sense that um you know
that it's the proud sort of capital
of the uk of england that has a very
specific
history um has a very specific
demographic
when it comes to uh you know the black
the black and asian minority ethnic
community
uh jamaicans wind rush
uh bangladesh etc other other
or london's london uh eu citizens as
well as as sadiq says that london is an
open city uh london london has unique
challenges and unique opportunities
and it is right that we seek to make
sure that london is a city for everybody
and everybody can enjoy it and that and
that
london is an open city um that firstly
everyone can
at the beginning first afford to even
live in and then also have a great have
a great time
and actually have yeah and have a decent
life and that the cost of living
is kept down reasonable and first and
foremost
what do you need housing food water
education etc and that's why housing is
such a key policy
uh nationally but definitely in london
where london is
is several several times more expensive
than every other place
in the uk and actually on earth and
that's why it's right to do this i love
london and i agree i agree that we
should have affordable housing
you say new york out of all the places
you feel it's worked the best
it's been it's been going in new york
now rent control was introduced i think
uh
about 50 years ago it's been a long long
time
from in the 60s and 70s over 200 000
rental units
became empty after they brought in rent
control how has it helped new york
prices are higher than ever
there's more homeless people so if
that's the place that you pick as
the best example how in what way is it
being good for new york i didn't pick
new york as the best example i i picked
new york as an
example okay and also just to be clear
on that and also
the housing the the problem the the
challenge of housing is a much more
complicated problem than that that has
many different facets
uh including how much how much budget
could councils actually have
to actually build build council housing
uh how much regulation to
how much regulation is there and how is
that actually implemented
um what are the unique challenges and
opportunities within those cities
um what's lambeth like versus southwark
versus
uh versus fulham in kensington and
chelsea it's a very unique
uh each city and each borough has very
unique challenges and very unique
things that need to be dealt with and
regulated and is absolutely right
that that the labour party or anyone who
has the privilege to be elected to serve
in in a in a public office in a publicly
held office should do their absolute
best
to make sure that everyone is
represented
and make sure that things are fair and
that's exactly what we're doing
on housing on education and on other
issues but just to focus on housing
it's not about if the policy work it's
not about
what it's not about if the philosophy of
the policy is correct
because we actually all would agree that
there should be affordable housing
it's about how it's implemented correct
and in terms of how it's implemented
we're going to go through a very very
thorough and very fair process
to make sure that all that all sides of
the argument
are represented and in the end the
actual legislation that will come out
if boris johnson allows the mayor the
office of the mayor to have this power
and if the department for communities
and local government does it the actual
policy that will come out will be a good
one
and guess what it won't be perfect but
you know what
we'll amend and we'll learn and we'll
keep growing and growing just like
you're just like a business does just
like your business does just like my
business does
you don't get it it doesn't have to be
perfect there's no such thing as a
perfect society but there is a good
society
and um it's our duty yeah
it's our duty you and me as citizens to
participate in the physical process and
it's the duty of politicians to do their
best to serve
and that's exactly what sadiq's doing
and i believe in siddique and i back
today 100
to be mayor of london why do you think
that in 2016
when sadiq was asked about rent control
he said just because it's a popular idea
doesn't mean there's a good one
yeah i i can't comment on behalf of the
mayor i'm not here to do that
what i can and i'm not sure that that
i'm not quite entirely sure
that that that that quotation has been
is entirely correct i
i don't know if you ever heard him
actually say that yeah yeah
but if even if that was the case we're
now
four years on or five years on now we've
had uh more of an opportunity to develop
the policy and think about how it's been
implemented
we've been able to learn from other
cities and like i said it's not just as
simple as what it's not as simple as
render controls or not it's about how
you do it
in politics you have you have the aim
yeah the method the implementation yeah
and then the learnings yeah yeah and
then you go back around and you do it
again how do you think then it will be
different to
because i i don't think it's worked ever
i mean when i asked you to name one
place where it's worked about positive
change
you know you said he said new york which
i think it devastated
but if you're saying it could work if it
was in a different way
yeah which is fair enough how are we
gonna how are we gonna bring rent
control in
in a different way what's gonna be
different about how you would like to
see it done in london
than in the other places where it's
where it's failed well the fact that it
will go through a process
the fact that it goes through that
process um
where people like yourself have an
opportunity to be actually part of that
discussion in the first place
and give your view and and help shape
that policy
as well as um tenant organizations like
generation rent can go for that process
i believe in it's not about how it's
going to be different i believe in the
political process
i believe in the values and i believe in
what we're trying to achieve
and i know that youth that you are very
passionate about
getting involved in politics and about
you know your sense of duty
aren't you yeah and in that respect then
india in that respect then
it is right for the office of the mayor
to have that power to set up that
commission
it's great for you to for people like
you and me to be able to participate
and it's right and i do and it's right
that it goes through that process and
then we do come to a policy
a policy that works and if it doesn't if
it's not perfect we'll just amend it and
learn and keep going and going and
growing and growing
just like everything else so to the
short verse the short answer to your
question samuel
is that it's not a simple yes or no
answer it's not a black and white answer
politics is shade of grey it's
our shades of grey and um everything
like every single policy like every
other business like every other
uh like everything in the world is a
learning process and what it really
counts on
is what what values do you have first do
you believe in the leader
do you does the does that particular
leader have the right values
um to implement a policy or to represent
what i believe in and represent people
and in this case yes sydney does
i know he does i understand what you're
saying and it sounds to me you're
you're not fair is that is that fair
listen
you're a smart person but it does sound
a little bit like what you're saying is
there's a problem i really like sadiq
and i'm sure it'll be okay and let's
just let him do like renkins doesn't
work
it's historically proven to not work
look with respect
um i don't agree with you
in that sense and it's i don't think
that it's a simple question of if it
works or not
it's about how it's implemented and what
parts of it have worked what possibly
haven't
and how um how and i learned this from
you
when something doesn't work you don't
just give up you say how can i
and you do it agree and and at the end i
agree with that
but what i would argue in this instance
yeah is
there is a problem right with with with
people
not being able to afford rents in london
yes there needs to be
affordable housing people need to be
able to
you know it's not good for people to be
priced out of the market i would
i would agree with that and i think that
the solution to that is two things
number one is i think that it's more
houses
i think we need to we need to have more
houses number two it'll be good if wages
went up
right if people because because the
house prices and rents are going up but
but
but wages haven't really gone up much
that's a whole other conversation
but in terms of london here's the thing
right
right now there's so many commercial
properties in london
that are empty right because offices
have moved out
there's massive opportunity right now in
london for developers
to go into london to turn the commercial
officers
the right the right kind of developers
with the right values well
unfortunately unfortunately all the
developers don't have the right aim
doesn't matter
even if they're greedy fat cat
developers
if they don't have the right fire safety
standards oh yeah that's the best but
that's a separate issue
it's not a separate issue housing itself
is upon it is
an entirely positive housing yeah is a
is an
entire uh policy area and policy remit
that we will address in a in the way
that you're saying in a
multi-dimensional way
so it's about making more so actually
sadiq's policy isn't just about rental
controls on rent or private rental
commissions yeah
it's about it's about hitting it from
multiple for multiple points
which i probably agree with that's right
so that was great it sounds like it
sounds like you do support sydney
in a more holistic sense probably not
but maybe okay well let me explain what
i mean by that
i agree with you that we need some more
more housing i agree with you that wages
need to be higher i agree with you that
we need to look at commercial properties
i also agree with i also agree with the
fact that there should be
a private rental commission that that
looks at that policy in a way that
represents all the values yeah
and we're looking to do all of those
things at once
and that is our housing policy agenda
and i appreciate that you're focused on
rental controls
but but from the perspective of the
labour party we need to look at it in a
much more holistic sense
and in the way in that real in that way
i actually think that we're coming to
quite a common position here
and now i have a question for you guys
go on so if the private rent if if the
mayor does win or if but when he wins
yeah he probably will when he wins and
he
and and if boris johnson does
take our mandate the mandate of the
mayor who will win by millions
by win in london and represent 8.4
million
people in the greater london area um and
he gets those powers to create the
private rental commission
and people like yourselves are like
yourself are invited
are invited to participate in that
policy making process will you show up
yeah all right well in that case then
that's great
and let's do it and yeah that's how
that's and that is no let's not do it
let's not do rent control no i'm not i'm
not saying let's do rental control i'm
saying let's all participate in politics
and make sure
yeah is that something that you agree
with i agree with that but let's say one
point
thank you let me say one point really
really really important i need i need i
need to get this off my chest
please do if i if i may right please
if i may so there's properties in london
right now commercial properties
where the offices have moved out because
of the pandemic yes and they're empty
and they're crying out fix me up and
turn me into a residential
unit if that happens that's gonna
bring the rent down right yeah rents
have dropped since it's been in power by
10
naturally they've gone down
when developers go in and convert these
commercial offices which
which are empty at the moment into
residential apartments what's happening
is the rents are going to come down i'm
like yes it's great
we're on the same team but if rent
control comes in
all the developers are going to go
actually i've changed my mind and
they're going to go and they're going to
do in birmingham i'm going to have a
bigger problem on our hands in london
okay well firstly uh when it comes to
the commercial property
just like with the rental private rental
commission we're gonna do that slowly
if we were to do something like that we
do that slowly we'll do that properly
we'll do it with a proper process we'll
have a proper consultation yeah
people like yourself will be involved if
you want to participate
and yes we want developers to do that
but they need to have the right values
and they need to have they need to they
need to uh bring in the right safeties
and they need to care about tenants
and i know you do and i know i do i know
we do
so um again all i can really say is i'm
gonna send you the link for when
for when all right we have those
consultations and i'd love to see you
there
we'll participate together and um uh
just on on all of that i just want to
say
uh i back sadiq khan for many reasons i
think i believe in him as a candidate he
shares the values
he comes from he comes from humble
beginnings he understands
he understands the perspectives of of
those of us who
you know weren't born with silver spoons
and that's why he's a great candidate
and um i can't remember your candidate's
name but that's
that's kind of the problem i don't
really have a candidate sean bailey sean
bailey's conservative party yeah but but
but i said
i'm not here to talk about sadiq khan
yeah i'm sure he's a lovely guy i've
never met him yeah right
i just don't think the rent control is
the right
way to bring down prices in london i
think that it's a
flawed philosophy that doesn't work
however i think we can both agree that
uh it's important that we discuss these
issues
yeah at the right meeting where
decisions are made because decisions are
made by people who show up
and there's a meeting and there's a
proper actual there's a proper meeting
where
where you'll be able to participate in
that process okay and now trust and
trust me you can have a great influence
on the actual policy on what actually
happens
yeah and by the way you said it's not
really about sadiq's about right now it
is about sadiq
because your business is called property
investors with samuel leeds
meaning it's your brand it's whether or
not people believe in you
and that first they believe in you as
samuel lee's because you are
a role model and an example of someone
who come
you you if if i made based on your book
he came from a
a sort of a normal background and was
able to build himself up
well siddique is no different to you in
that regard he just chose to he just
chose to get involved in politics
and chose to serve and he's serving in a
different way and now let's all serve
together and let's all get involved and
let's
let's do some great stuff all right
thanks for um
hakeem for coming out what do you think
is rent control a good idea or
is it actually gonna hurt the people
it's supposed to help
is siddique right am i right what do you
think
comment below in the comment box and i
appreciate you coming out once again
thank you